[Music] [Applause] [Music]
greetings ladies and gentlemen Live From The
Improv [__] I'm here to do a tip [__] 15
for you ladies and gentlemen uh no no that's a
lie that's a lie in the name of trying to make
you laugh I'm gonna do a loose 180 very loose
welcome kids to fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith
I am Mark Bernard hey oh uh I am in New Jersey
above a movie theater I am in Southern California
in an office slash uh like guess the the scare
floor yeah look at you monstr Inc um the uh Mike
wasowski back hello wasowski my kid was little
when Monsters Inc came out my God that was such
a big factor in our house told this story before
but like you know the Pixar was like hey will you
give us a quote for an Oscar ad and I was like
yeah as if [__] Oscar voters listen to me what
am I Damen chazelle and so uh I gave him some
quote and as a thank you they sent me the giant
Sully and Mike that used to be in movie theaters
oh [__] three dimensional made of like thick
styrofoam with real fur on it and [__] like that
so I was like oh my God these are astounding and
um we unpacked them from these giant crates
and put them in Harley's room Harley was like
three at the time and uh you know I was like
oh my god when she [__] walks in a room she's
gonna pass the [__] out man this is like this is
unbelievable kid comes in the room and she's just
like wow and then goes and does a zillion other
things that's when I realized oh I was like Wow
because I grew up [__] poor this kid grew up you
know with stuff so to her it wasn't like oh my God
this is the greatest thing that ever happened to
me to her it was just like oh San micer here of
course is that is that a like jaded from privilege
or just the three-year-old imagination she's like
of course my friends are here there is no dividing
line between imaginary and real the very next
thing she said Mark was uh I want a pony now daddy
now ask an answer counselor she was just um you
know she had honestly like she had big stuffed
downal she had a big like stuffed uh teddy bear
that we called Charlie Quinn that Joe Casada and
Nancy Casada uh gave us before the kid was born
was huge so she was used to like big things I
guess in her room but these things were [__]
huge honestly I felt like insanely successful
when I saw those crates at my house I was like
what popped it open I was like I'm I've done it
like that was my oscar moment right there brought
to you by the Oscar close as all ofg and and I
probably love them more um how's everybody doing
kids forgot they can't [__] respond uh me
and Mark coming at you all over your face
neck and chest and [__] B man probably
popping in from time to time as well that
your cute you no he's off mik we're we're
Flying Blind on a rocket cycle there he is
how you doing there bamp man I'm okay I uh
I'll tell you what's weird my two-year-old
daughter is obsessed with Nightmare
Before Christmas well that's twoy old
daughter has good [__] taste not scared
like we're going to bed and Oogie Boogie
is my friend is what she's saying crazy bro
take take that kid to Hot Topic or head will
[__] yeah take it to the Bowl take it to the
bowl for uh for the The Nightmare Before Christmas
concert and who is it this year I read it's like
Hy alternating with uh kathern O'Hara s will be
no Paul Rubin uh Danny Elfman of course he's
him and every one of his [__] 10,000 muscles
will squeeze into Hollywood Bow that guy's [__]
ripped now man yolked senior citizen holy [__]
and he is a senior citizen like he's [__] 70
years yeah but like gez man the old people today
don't look like the old people of my youth do
you remember when when JK Simmons was working
out to play Commissioner Gordon and Gordon and
he had [__] guns what are you doing I was like
that's that that and Harvey Bullock are two of
the only Parts don't have to get beefed up man
he was [__] he too was just like look at the gun
show and [__] close your eyes Batman because the
gun show yeah Gary oldman's on an all scone
diet meanwhile JK Simmons is here just [__]
shredding um you know go just looking back so
that movie's 30 years old which is insane but
I I was doing trivia the other night at the bar
and uh I do a category that I call three actors
and a year and so I'll give three actors in the
year and you have to tell me what movie it is and
I did a movie from 19 1990 through 1999 um and I
was like man the '90s had a lot of great movies
and and the bar giggled at me as if like as if I
was being funny or something like the like the 90s
movies sucked so I looked up movies of just 1993
you know how many M great movies are turning or
at least entertaining movies are turning Jurassic
Park Schindler's List Robin Hood Men and tights
Demolition Man Groundhog Day True Romance
Dazed and Confused The Sandlot The Firm mask
of the fantasm Mrs Doubtfire The Fugitive in the
line of fire Hocus Pocus Tombstone What's Eating
Gilbert Grape Caro's way Cone Heads falling down
Nightmare Before Christmas that's like 20 of like
every weekend there was a movie that came out that
you wanted to see that's better than like the last
decade and Cone Heads that is yeah and con heads
that is the uh that's all the mov movies that
were playing right before like uh I took clerks to
Sundance then because then in 94 like clerks we're
coming up on 2024 man right now we just passed
October 3D the 30th anniversary of clerk's going
to the iffm the independent feature film Market
where we thought like we're dead nobody's gonna
see this movie and then that's where the ball
started rolling because Bob Hawk saw a flick um
so that means January is the 30th anniversary of
us going to Sundance with clerks um so right now
I've been making films for 30 years but we're
coming up on the 30th anniversary of like the
world knowing at the end of the 2024 in October
it's the 30th anniversary of the release of the
movie so naturally you know don't don't think
for a second I'm not going to be [__] like
30 years Clerks all year long and [__] are you
taking are you taking the 4:30 movie to Sundance
I'm hoping man I hope I mean I hope that's up to
Sundance hopefully we get to show it to him in
the next week or two because I got a cut together
for those that don't follow that closely I just
finished making a movie called The 430 movie um
I got a a sag waiver kids so we were shooting and
um hopefully it's cut it's all pretty much cut
together um JC's seen it JC what think I love
it uh I've been working on stuff with you since
since you finished Red State I joined up with
you when you were touring Red State and I think
this is I loved clerks 3 but I think this is my
favorite movie we've worked on a man thank you
and actually Jason what's that am I good in it
I don't even remember you in it uh but it's funny
because I and I'm not saying that because I'm like
well my voice is in it like it was clerks I wasn't
even there like I started on the movie after you
were like hey I'm done with it here uh so it's
uh I love it I'm excited for everybody to see
it ah me too man it turned out uh really really
sweet it's very sweet very very um dreamy little
picture um JC before it like like referen the
sand lot and I was like not not wrong it it's
not I mean not like plot-wise or anything
but right in terms of like how it makes you
feel ni uh um but yeah that was uh why did that
come up again Big Year big year yeah that's 30
years of [__] clerks um 30 years of Clerks
and this jerk um so all year long don't forget
kids we're gonna be cramming that in your [__]
face a gonna let you forget is that a f is that a
is that a super chat in in the chat um are we
back to that sort of thing oh no JC oh that's
that wasn't me somebody else turned that on I
didn't do it I didn't break that lamp I swear
eventually that's will Wilkins will Wilkins is
like let's dial it up he's like no sponsor tonight
so um the uh kids we got a show for you kind of
look at this I got a table that goes up and down
ready this the elevator this how yeah I'll
be back in a minute I gotta go get to the
wine [Laughter] seller um what uh what are we
gonna talk about with these folks let's give
them a preview um well we uh each of us has now
seen two episodes of the Loki show season two
the Loki show I wish it was called the Loki show
yes the Loki show brought to you by Proctor and
Gamble and Patriot brand cigarettes um there's
some New York ComicCon news um that will sort
of fold into our standard news Gathering LDA um
there's some some plugs that I think both of us
are going to want to make about events Andor
products coming down the pike true um and then
there's there's this [__] News man news um I
am back East because we just had the SM Castle
fil Festival uh this last weekend um it opened on
Thursday night with uh sa Rogers chasing Chasing
Amy then continued through Friday Saturday Sunday
we did Awards and it was absolutely lovely second
annual SM Castle Film Festival um and looks
like we'll be doing a third of course and then
I was going to head home but um there's another
thing that I'm doing out here on Thursday which
is JC can you throw up that link the friends
of firefighters Gala benefit uh this is the
organization um that grew out of uh the September
11th attacks and after September 11th attacks we
had a bunch of First Responders and folks who
you know were dealing with uh the mental health
issues and physical health issues and whatnot
so this organization wonderful organization
called friends of firefighters um that Bushi is
a member of as well Steve Bushi um they're doing
their fundraising Gala on Thursday in Brooklyn
and so I'm the MC they're also full disclosure
giving me some sort of award which is very sweet
of them so I'm in town uh for that b man do you
did I I sent that link can you throw that up I I'm
working on it it uh it's requiring me to log in so
I I'll have it up in two seconds keep keep keep
chatting no worries whatsoever um that's what I'm
doing on uh Thursday so that's kept me out here
and then Friday I'll head back back West um to
the land of Los Angeles how you been what you've
been up to you know man it's been uh it's been a
good couple of weeks I guess since the last time
we did this maybe it was last week the last time
we did it maybe to talk about the first episode
of Loki in the finale of Ahsoka I think had to
be last week yeah had to be last week um you know
kind of work is beginning to heat up you know now
that the WJ strike is over now that development
is starting a new there's there's the smell of
uh of opportunity is in the air so I'm [__] out
there shaking my ass the track like one does um
had a comic book announced at New York ComicCon
this uh this past weekend um I uh JC is so busy
logging into Instagram there it is look at you
uh I on the heels of the Darth Vader uh short
story that I did for their Anthology Darth Vader
black white and red they asked me if I wanted to
write a miniseries about mace Wu and I said
yes I do I don't know I'm GNA I don't know
I'm what I'm gonna make W do do but I'll figure
that [__] out um they would not let me just
uh reenact Pulp Fiction with mace Wu they they
actually expected some sort of story could you
keep this kind of in the universe I was like
okay but can he say [__] a lot like no I'm
afraid he can't the false [__] do you wield it
like no you can't do that you can't do that look
at you man that's two Star Wars stories you got
to write I know it's been fun it's been fun kid
who like [__] saw Star Wars when when he was
a just a youngster in [__] shortpants running
around dreaming dreaming about sci-fi and [__]
geeking out before he found Star Trek he's like me
The Little Rascals PE p p and then one day you
get to grow up to [__] do this and get notes
from [__] Lucas film I'm sure right like yeah
man somebody makes sure that you're not like you
know and then ma Wu pulls out a giant cocktail
like oh no he doesn't yeah Star Wars censor does
Yoda look like a [__] Anakin then why are you
trying to [__] him 1994 great year for movies
indeed that's tremendous congratulations to you
my friend thank you that comes out in January
four issues of Mace windy goodness at you man
next up [__] they'll just hand you one of
them star Wars TV series that keep giving out to
everybody would you like to do a star war yes I
would can I make this one good though um flu 1775
in chat says D does marcelus Wallace look like a
Sith that is very I know the puns they just which
lightsaber is yours the one who says bad [__]
on it Michael ochre in chat says doesn't Kevin
look a little high I wish no it's tired I was
drinking some Celsius that's my new [__] speed
right here man you got one I got mine you got a
grape I got a grape look at that gra AE it's a
free ad right there they're not pay I poured mine
into a little cup that has ice in it so I can
just make it last longer you pretending you're
at a party I'm going get get your red [__]
Solo Cup and [__] some some some Celsius pong
yeah I haven't been to the movies much lately
because you know it's it's a bit of a dirth of
the movie theater unless you're a Taylor Swift
fan in which case yeah now's your time yeah oh
my good Lord that was playing here at SM Castle
right downstairs congruent with the SM Castle
Film Festival so you had a bunch of c easts and
a bunch of tween girls um raing theaters at the
same time yeah look I'm no I'm I'm not a Swifty
and not by virtue of the fact like I don't like
her music I just I know one song and you know I
like it but um but I respect what she got going
on and [__] clearly very talented she's also
a writer I respect the [__] out of that but
as an exhibitor Mark as a movie theater owner
oh let me tell you I like this girl very much
ER Greta Gerwig [__] Chris Nolan these are
my favorite people Chris Pratt both the Mario
Brothers these are my favorite people this year
when it comes to film exhibition um so she did
a solid by shooting that [__] flick man she
didn't have to do that did you have a like a
like a a plethora of teenage girls dancing in
your theater yeah I popped my head in one of
the theaters at one point and oh my God they
shot the [__] out of this movie Man like
literally 35 cameras there was so many [__]
Cuts where it's like bang bang bang it's not
like four cameras and they're cutting the for
an angles there were [__] cameras everywhere
she looked like she was having a real good
time up on that St I'm sure counting every
[__] billion of her billions of dollars and
stuff do you think that watches like the Taylor
Swift movie and goes like you know what when I
shot the last Walts I had three [__] cameras I
know um yeah it's uh from what I saw when I was
standing there watching I also watched a few
minutes of Paw Patrol got thoughts I have notes um
the the dogs don't act like that Mark I've got two
dogs they don't [__] act like that no not too
much that uh but when I sat in for a few minutes
on the Taylor SP F because you can do that when
you the movie theater um it it seemed joyous and
the kids were having a good time that were there
to see it you know like little girls when like
six seven eight year old girls get up and dance
they're just like they stand up and like just they
know how to dance that's I sat the theater I was
like you can't dance sit down I said they're just
like the the wavy things outside of car ships
yes getting rid them it was lovely though um
seeing the kids uh and uh their parents of course
just like we something to do we yeah we'll be in
the back on our phones you kids have fun um but
uh yeah man I also watched today Jen and I went
downstairs and watched dumb money the movie about
the GameStop scandal or not GameStop uh what do
they call that uh I don't know starring uh Pete
Davidson St stock incident yeah uh with Paul Dano
Pete Davidson shylene Woodley Seth [Music] Rogan
good movie directed by Craig Gillespie uh good
flick nobody's they didn't have a way to Market
it got like great cast but once again and you
know we're in the midst of a strike still so they
can't be out there talking about it and stuff yeah
I suppose we can we can deliver a tiny sag strike
update I am not nearly as informed about the
SAG strike as I was the wga strike because let's
let's finish off the wga strike they signed we all
signed everything done and we were we all ratified
the the contract that's presented by 99% of the
members who voted voted to ratify there were some
1% 90 people were like [__] this deal and uh and
didn't vote for it but that's a a very very Teensy
Min minority of the majority and so writers are
back to work writers rooms are up and running
um there's there's still an open debate where
those writers rooms are um because there are some
showrunners who do not want to cross a picket line
and so the offices that used to be on Studio lots
that are actively picketed by by sag like I won't
cross that line give me know give me Wei work
somewhere give me a give me an office in the the
back of his Staples but I don't want to cross that
line but if you were working you're back to work
um if you were not working you're back to looking
for work and so that's the that's the deal that's
where it is and sag I think is on day they're in
the high 80s of their strike they they have been
going great guns I believe with the studios um
they were meeting every other day um with with the
negotiating team the the negotiations committee
on behalf of sag and then the the studio heads I
think they had four or five legit Studio heads
in the room um and I think that some of it was
the reason they were meeting every other day is
because the actors because sag had some 30 or so
maybe even 40 points of contention like here are
are the deal points we want to address whereas
the writer really only had eight or nine and so
you could digest that information overnight where
if you've got to go through a phone book of of
asks and counters and uh and negotiations that
takes time but as of last week the studi walked
away from the table again um you know for reasons
that nobody can ever seem to understand other
than they're trying to split the the membership
of the union and cause some internal disarray uh
it's the same thing they did with the writers it
doesn't work um but it's their playbook and so
they they keep on running it and much like with
the wrers when we got to day 148 and made a deal
uh that could have been made in 3 days the actors
are beginning to feel the same way which is you
know you're going to make a deal you know you're
GNA have to give a bit and will have to give a
bit um but this weird political you know counter
intelligent scop [__] of like let's let's just
walk away let's take our game and go home is not
advantageous for anybody so um they are cruising
up on 100 days um and I've been walking the line
like you know once maybe twice a week I'll I'll
grab my wga and support of sag picket sign and
I'll walk out there and uh you know Spirits are
still high but somehow the lines don't feel as
deep as I would have expected for a guild the size
of sag so you're an actor out there does it feel
like that's going to close or end soon I know they
walked away this week but like maybe that's why
people aren't walking the line so much I mean it
it what you'd hope is that it would encourage them
to to come out in force you know it would have the
opposite effect it's like oh they walked away fine
we will show them how strong we are by giving it
a strong show of solidarity on the lines and get
out there and and March um it has to be over soon
because what's going to end up happening is the
writers are back to work and they're writing
the scripts that the actors would shoot and
so the hope is if you're going to save you know
winter 2024 then you need to start shooting before
Thanksgiving of 2023 which means the actors will
need a deal so doesn't feel like you can go on
for that much longer if the studios want to save
the fiscal year uh next year um but who knows they
don't seem to be always operating logically Brazil
201 in chat says in New York the lines are massive
but I don't know why La isn't popping I don't
know either I mean and it's not even that it's
theater actors because they can be working um but
maybe it's because New York only has a couple of
picket locations they're not quite spread as thin
but you know the wga's membership was some 100 11
12,000 people and sag is about 160,000 people so
it feels like that's a lot of people who could be
walking who don't seem to be walking um meanwhile
on the right Guild side everyone's going back to
work we've we the thing we were working on before
months ago before the strike happened we get to go
start resuming discussions about yeah yeah the the
world is beginning to at least gently slowly write
itself and uh huh right puns and so yeah we're
going to be back at it darudy and chat uh was
wrote something and then wrote like yeah ignore
it as usual um so that made me scroll back to see
what he's talking about and he said or she said
the actors came out for the writers but as soon
as the writers got their deal they abandoned the
actors do you do you agree with that Mark um no
because the actors when they could work did work
um because they're contractually obligated to do
so um there is a no sympathy strike clause in
in both Guild's contract um you can decide not
to cross a picket line and some actors did if
there was a picket line outside their their
set their location Sun acers didn't cross it
some did and that's fine like as as to each to
their own um but as I said we're not Crossing
picket lines we're going back to work because
again our contract requires us to um but we're not
going to cross a line and go back to work on the
Warner Brothers lot or on the Disney lot that's
that's what the picket does um so there's that
that weirdness the disconnect I suppose on what
some people saw and did during The Writers Guild
strike you know there were actors who walked on
the lines with us who were also working you know
but they walked because they believed in what we
were doing but had to do their jobs because they
signed a contract requiring them to do that job
same with us in chat Gwen said wjga and sag are
in solidarity no one as abandon anyone correct we
are supporting as much as we can support um shall
we dive into the news because people are starting
to ask questions that are kind of news related for
example Dwayne Atley is asking is NBC Universal
going to buy Warner Brothers is that in the news
do you have anything about that um it is it is a
rumor um it is not a thing that is in motion but
you know the the belief had always been that the
way David zaslov has been treating Warner Brothers
Discovery has been you know trimming the fat for
an eventual sale to somebody um getting all of
their tax burdens in line you know shrinking the
workforce minimizing their taxes all of that stuff
killing movies that maybe people should have seen
is all in an effort to to make the company more
attractive to a buyer um and the theory the
theory seems to be is well who could for to
buy Warner Brothers and there's about a handful of
people who could then NBC Universal is one of them
um as is Apple if they wanted to as is Amazon
if they wanted to um um but there's no there's
no current like negotiations in that regard but
you know it it is not by any stretch out of the
realm of possibility that in the next few years
um even though we have antitrust laws that seem
to be maybe guidelin and not laws anymore that
giant companies buying giant companies to form
another giant Voltron company is probably not a
great idea um but nobody seems to care so I guess
that's what's gonna happen George DD in chat says
I can guarantee you the NBC would not get the sign
off from the government to buy Warner he probably
right too big right I mean Disney got the sign off
to buy Fox yeah good point Amazon got the sound
off to buy MGM like everything is possible bam
hey man what up B man C can I ask uh as writers
is people who have to work in this industry does
it really worry you guys when it's like well I
have two employers it's either NBC Universal or
it's Disney or or I guess three or it's Apple
because if you piss one person off not that I
have any experience pissing off one of those
corporations in any way shape or form but all
of a sudden you can't work with any of the other
ones so like nothing Marvel will have anything
to do with scum and villainy nothing uh at all so
is that I mean is that really what the fear is of
just like well you know I do work with Hollywood
Reporter if I fall out with Hollywood Reporter
I also fall out with like dead spin Rolling
Stone billboard uh variety variety you know
it's just like well that's it like if you work in
entertainment journalism it's like Entertainment
Weekly and Pensky media like is that is that just
a giant fear is that just about controlling the
N completely controlling the narrative Charles
Foster Kane is that where we're at I mean it's
it's it's not good because as a as a person who
sells things you want lots of places to be able
to sell that thing yeah and if suddenly what used
to be eight places buying becomes seven becomes
six becomes five that's less opportunities to sell
the thing you know like when you used you used to
be able to pitch you know Disney proper used to be
able to pitch Fox proper you know you used to be
able to pitch [__] lucasfilm proper or Pixar
proper they were all buyers of things and then
once they all get under the same corporate you
know umbrella that's less ability for you to find
the market for what you're selling and it's not
great so if it all comes down to ultimately two
companies left then you know sure they'll still
make stuff and sure some of those Executives at
Fox search light have a budget to buy stuff but
it's not as if they didn't have to deal with some
giant corporate Synergy initiative they could just
[__] go out on the L and I believe in this let's
do that it's not as easy anymore so yeah I'm
I'm not gonna say I'm deeply afraid of it the
way I am of like spiders but it's not it's not a
healthy business environment to not have a healthy
Marketplace spiders antitrust keeping me out of
work one of those things is always closer than the
other um the chat is full of people wanting to
talk about stuff like the a24 pivot you read
about that no what's their pivot they also want
to talk about Best Buy announcing they're done
with physical media start yeah the a24 pivot to
like we want Blockbuster filmmakers which a24 I
guess is uh looking for more IP properties um
you know because you know not every not every
movie is everything everywhere all at once I mean
if I'm an a24 executive I start like shopping and
sifting through public domain like I start saying
like what's our version of The Little Mermaid
what's a a24 movie that that's [__] Winnie the
Poop which is not public domain right you know
like rather than in instead of shopping for like
give us you know [__] I mean I who knows what
this is just a report that was in the press that
they're like yeah we're open to or they've been
taking meetings about meeting with about doing
bigger things looking for bigger properties and
whatnot and that's got folks scared online because
they're like no it was a good small perfect thing
I guess in short Mark Bo is afraid uh and B is the
internet and the internet's afraid that the modern
day mirax a24 the uh the most interesting film
Distribution Company currently in the business
uh is going to become somehow less interesting I
say no I don't think that's necessarily going to
mean that they're going to stop making all the
movies they've made they're just also trying to
get hits so that they can continue making the
weirdness that's what I hope I mean I think
they've they've figured out you know they're one
of the few um production companies that has an
aesthetic like you know an a24 movie when you see
it which it feels a lot like HBO used to be in the
early 2000s it's not TV it's HBO and you knew
an HBO show when you when you watched it and so
is there a way to scale up what a24 means like
yeah there there absolutely is in the same way
that Miramax would do tiny [__] movies nobody
ever heard of and then a crime game and then Pulp
Fiction and then you know we'll spend some money
and we'll we'll make a thing that nobody else
would make that's all that means then hey go for
it be the Blum House of Art House um feels like a
decent way to go um and Best Buy uh I guess has
announced that they're done with physical media
as of the first of the year so Christmas this is
it for like you know that's why I was doing those
[__] tremendous steelbox for various Blu-rays
and some old some new but they're getting out of
physical media man which means the price of that
shit's going to go up don't mean it's goingon to
go away kids there'll still be people making stuff
it's just but now can't offset the cost with you
know like a couple pallets going off to to Best
Buy so probably means per unit cost of of physical
media you know that we Blu-rays and whatnot will
probably go up a little bit but it doesn't mean
the end of it never going away it's like records
man there's always gonna [__] do you know how
many vhs's people bring me now and F because now
you can also get those authenticated and slabbed
SE old vhs's that have never been open that still
have like the logo on the [__] rap like Bo of
to home video or MCA Universal or something like
that um so yeah they'll always be physical media
kids but Best Buy dropping out of the game is
it's a shame it's a blow it is you know and I
think that especially as people begin to realize
that there was a convenience and a permanence to
physical media that you do not get in a streaming
environment when like you had it you had it nobody
could take it away nobody could unlicense it
from it from you nobody could come in your
house and decide you know what you don't get to
watch Robocop anymore because we've not sold the
rights to another streamer and so it's not on this
one the one you had a subscription to if it's in
your house you can watch it um and you know I
think that people are beginning to to remember
how uh what it was like to be a collector and
that there was some joy to be had in there like
[__] Criterion had a wicked sale today did
you did you see this 50% off every Criterion
disc um for 24 hours and I went a little [__]
nuts for a dude who doesn't currently have a job
and almost spent like $200 buying Criterion
today look you give me these Blu-rays give
me these Blu-rays um so yeah it's it's I think
you're right I think it'll become like records
I think it'll become a a a not even bespoke but
way more of a ob based collector's medium and
like yeah you might end up spending 50 bucks for
a DVD um you want it our friend Josh mundall on
in a Super Chat asked us Kevin did you receive
the Gil Gerard uh Buck Rogers DVD box set yeah
he had gifted me that I did receive that thank
you very much it inspired you to create a ranger
danger comic or an animated series yet to p p
PCH to Netflix um no but there's something in
the 430 movie that is in that Buck Rogers realm
uh thank you Josh you're very very sweet man
it's a $20 Super Chat right there my friend $20
Super Chat D that's that's good for a good dozen
csuses that's true me and Mark buy the drink that
won't sponsor us nope to be fair we didn't ask hey
speaking of sponsor or speaking of [__] you
can buy if you go to a website called um what's
that website called Mercantile Instinct that's
Malcolm Ingram's website you can buy the clerk
Blu-ray my life documentary about my life with
this awesome little sleeve that goes over it
this o-ring is they call it in the business uh
go to mertile instinct. right now get your copy
of clerk um what else can we talk about you got
news um well uh we could get into the Loki of it
all and then hit the news or we could just dive
into the news Well actually the first news item
does dovea very nicely into Loki so we can do
that yeah let's do it I watched episode two as
did I story in progress nice to see e Eevee
back um you know give me a few more episodes
I uh I I caught up with the first episode and
watched the second episode and I have no idea
what's happening really like it's been a long
time since season one and so like pruning of
of timelines and sacred timeline and TVA This and
like it's it's all swimming a little bit over my
head um but I also don't care that much because I
just very much like watching Tom Heston and Owen
Wilson kind of just banter like the two of them
together is fun to watch and so I'll just watch
that and like the story will eventually begin
to make sense and you add KIU Kuan to that who's
just adorable um you know like it's it's it's
perfectly amiable viewing even though I don't
know yet what the story is you know episode one
ends with we got to find Sylvie okay why because
we just have to we need to know what and and cuz
she things happened at the end of the universe and
the man who shall not be named or whatever okay
yeah let's G do that and we're gonna spend some
time in a in an Old McDonald's yeah right cool
that's also fun you know like I just I don't get
it yet but maybe I'm not supposed to or maybe
as the internet is fond of saying I'm not smart
enough to get it same but it's also it speaks
volumes about the charm of that cast it's like
I'll take your journey because I like watching
these people and I'm not sure where you guys
are going just yet and I wish you'd get there
a lot sooner but uh yeah it continues to Pace
um and still insanely wellmade and well acted
um but you know as we've learned this week or
last week uh Marvel is doing something of a retcon
when it comes to their TV shows is that the story
that Dove tells ni that is the lead story this
week my friend it's everywhere that story man
yeah that was broken in the in The Hollywood
Reporter uh written by our man Boris kid um
Marvel slams the brakes on Daredevil and then
discovers how television Works um that uh yeah
they were making an 18 episode daredevil show dar
double born again um they had paused production in
mid June um during the writer strike um they had
shot about Nine episodes of it of the 18 um but
apparently it was enough for Marvel Executives
including Kevin flagy to review the footage
and Come Away with a clear-eyed assessment the
show wasn't working uh so in late September this
year Marvel quietly let go of head writers Chris
Orton Matt pman uh oh there's a thought in chat
that I'm like wow Taylor in chat says it'll
be awesome if Short Round is the new he who
remains okay could be right because right now he's
like an innocent adorable lovable little character
but maybe by the end he's a Kang be anyway back to
Daredevil um so yes the marvelous on the hunt for
new writers to oversee I suppose writing a whole
new show and using some of what had already been
shot but it's all of that is increasingly unclear
what exactly is happening um inside the the house
of ideas um you know according to and you know
CHR had some quotes from people on the record
like Brad windbound who's the head of streaming
television animation for and saying we're trying
to marry the Marvel culture with the traditional
television culture it comes down to how can we
tell stories in television that honor what's so
great about the source material um I think part
of the issue and it's a thing that is highlighted
there's a new book on stands called MCU the reign
of Marvel Studios yeah um which is fantastic like
it's a terrific book I I I got a a look at it
about a month ago or so um and it's amazing like
it they they interview some hundred people you
know from the very beginning of Marvel when they
were set up above a Beverly Hills Mercedes Benz
dealership all the way till now um and uh Joanna
Robinson was sort of the lead researcher and and
and I'm sorry the lead reporter and Dave Gonzalez
was the lead researcher and one of the things they
talk about is the Marvel method of making movies
which is you know Kevin feige would entrust a
filmmaker to go off and make the movie that they
wanted to make you know with lots of input from
the the Marvel Executives and whatever they would
build time into the production schedule so they
come back with a movie by and Company would look
at it and see what was missing and then go off and
shoot that stuff that was missing that's the way
they've done everything basically since ironment
the problem is that TV doesn't quite work that way
you know you actually need to have a showrunner a
writer who's in charge who's keeping the story in
their head the entire time both on set and in post
and it's infinitely harder to operate that way
we're like oh all right so here here's 10 hours
of content you know we now need to figure out how
to spot well this together so it makes sense two
hours is somewhat easier to do than 10 hours 18
hours of of television and so that seems to be
the fundamental you know flash of styles which is
television is its own Beast um television has been
made a certain way for 50 years um and it works
not to say that you can't innovate stuff because
people are innovating the ways you make television
all the time but you know you don't break it
unless it's broken and lots of people have made
fantastic television the way television gets made
and so from Marvel 2 now kind of come around like
oh you know what maybe we did need uh we did need
to have showrunners maybe we did need to involve
them in the entire process maybe we did need to
have somebody uh mining the shop at every turn
um you know like moonnight with with Oscar Isaac
and Ethan Hawk you know the Creator and writer
Jeremy Slater quit uh director Muhammad diab
took the Reigns um you know the writer of the show
was not there Jessica G developed and wrote chog
attorney at law but was sidelined once director
Kat Coro came aboard um you know like it's just
there's there's a Litany of these kinds of shows
especially Marvel shows that seem as if there's
just a ball being kind of handed over to lots of
different people you know secret Invasion um pal
Brad street who was a writer and AP on on Mr Robot
had been working on the scripts for a year when he
was fired after Marvel went a different direction
then a new guy named Brian Tucker came aboard um
with a new director and all of these pieces just
keep on moving and it's very hard to make a good
television show that way um and so yeah like even
Marvel is now coming around to saying it's like
you know what we might need showrunners it's a
term we've not only grown comfortable with but
also learned to embrace says Brad windbone um
we need Executives that are dedicated to this
medium uh that are going to focus on streaming
and focus on television because they and movies
are two different art forms so we'll see what
happens man but it's it's it's a little rocky
over there at the moment and it I suppose it it
helps that all parties concerned have decided to
slow down the production process you know Bob
Iger once he returned from the Wilderness was
like we're doing too much stuff like you're making
movies you might not need to make and there's way
too much television so let's just kind of I read
some today that said maybe Wonderman is going away
as well yeah that's a rumor that that Wonderman
which was like 90% shot um and stopped during the
the riter strike might be just a casualty of War
might be like you know what not going to finish
it you know Eko which has been bounced I think
into next year um which is going to be like a
Thanksgiving drop of just here you go enjoy the
binge it'll be the first it would have been the
first time the Marvel would have binged the thing
and that does not imply an overwhelming amount of
confidence um um well my heart goes out to
everyone that worked on that Daredevil um you
know just like my heart went out to everyone that
worked on [__] backgirl like could you imagine
putting all that time into something and I'm
not saying like good or bad I'm not commenting
on the quality but it's just like you put all
your time and effort into a thing and then you
know somebody's like nah yeah it's not working you
know like in apparently that daredevil show like
he wasn't in the suit for the first four episodes
of the show because they very much wanted it to
be like a legal procedural it's like I mean okay
but and when I say they I mean it was you know
marvel and probably not the the writers um that
is speculation I'm sure but like how do you not
put Daredevil in the Daredevil suit for four hours
of TV well you know Netflix the the series didn't
put him into the suit until the literal end
of the show they had him in a you know [__]
sleek black outfit where he put a you know thing
around his eyes but he didn't get into that suit
until the second or couple episodes toward the
end if I remember correctly did he get the mask
right but he's like in a suit doing Daredevil
things right you know look I'm I'm with you I
I did not need especially because they already
established the dude as Daredevil in She-Hulk
so it's like what are you waiting for episodes get
him in a suit for yeah like once you cast Charlie
Cox and once you bring Vincent denafo back and
once you know John barenthal is back like you're
you're Daredevil season three at this point so
just or or I don't remember how many they did on
Netflix they do three seasons in I think they
did three so this would be essentially season
four but they're you know they're it seemed like
I guess maybe they were trying to keep cost down
because you know their Daredevil bounces around
and [__] remember she jumped off buildings and
whatnot Netflix Daredevil just kicks the [__]
out of people in a Non-Stop hallway fight yeah
yeah and like that was also done under the the
the the Marvel TV you know the Jeff lobe era
you know and more to the point the ike PE mutter
like we're going to be as cheap as [__] possible
era and so they were never going to spend pingy
poity Daredevil money it was always going to be
gritty and dudes in hallways um which worked it
worked that first season Daredevil is great the
first season of Jessica Jones is great the first
season of of Luke Cage is great the first season
of Iron Fist exists um but yeah I don't know man
I don't know it just feels it feels like there
was it was due a change in in the operating style
for Marvel TV and it seems like change is going
to come Silas bar in chat said I promised this the
last time I mentioned that werewolf by night color
version showing this month Remember by night was
black and white I guess they got a color version
of yeah I I got a chance to meet Michael Gino at
a at a birthday party um a couple weeks back and
told him how much I uh I appreciate werewolf by
night and he seemed a he seemed a cool cat he did
a wonderful job uh all right what else we got Yo
shit's crazy on Aquaman 2 oh my Lord yeah my my
heart goes out to every [__] fellow DC fan man
it's just like can't win can't get a can't get a
bite man flash Shazam Blue Beetle and now are we
getting Aquaman by the end of this year or no uh
we're supposedly getting it you know I think that
that Warner Brother seems bullish on the strike
coming to an end so being able to have Mamoa out
there blacking it but yeah like variety had this
whole bit about the Amber herd and Johnny Depp
trial document surfacing surfacing and like all
kinds of alleged behavior on the part of mimoa who
was apparently allegedly drunk who dressed like
Johnny Depp and like he I I don't know that he
I mean I [__] I met him once on a plane seemed
like a nice guy but I I don't don't think he just
dressed like Johnny Depp I think that's he dresses
I don't think he dressed as Johnny Depp I think
he just kind of dresses like Johnny Depp layers
and [__] like that right I mean that's like
it's it's very like he said she said it's like
you know herds people are like this is the thing
that happened that was done intentionally to to
dispirit my client and then MIM moa's reps are
like hey he's not dressed like Johnny Depp he's
always dressed like a Bohemian like he's always
been in like blowy things and lots of ch and rings
and whatever yes you know it's like he's conducted
himself he's a professional all times on the set
of Aquaman and the lost kingdom does he like a
drink occasionally sure everybody does but he
doesn't show up drunk on set but like it's like
we talked about it before that all the re-shoot
years and years and years in of re- shoots but
like the more that comes out about this thing
the more it's like what the [__] you know yeah I
don't I don't know I I've I saw the one thing that
like you know um that I I read in the news that I
was like well I I guess I can understand that was
um they were having test screenings and spoilers
kids I don't know if they're going to continue
doing this in the movie but they did this once in
the comics so spoil ERS for that as well in the
comics many years ago Black Manta killed Aquaman's
son the aqua baby aquad Aqualad him and him and uh
mir's baby so that's pretty famous comic book
storyline and it sounds like they included a
version of that in this new Aquaman movie where
uh black uh Manta kills Aquaman and mirror's baby
and you know [__] audiences walked out they were
like [__] this so I can get my head around that
if some audience is like I don't [__] come to no
superhero movie to watch a [__] baby die but you
know the comic book guy in me was like well that's
what they did in the comics uh so it sounds like
that's probably GNA go away it sounds like they've
been changing this movie so much dude they had
minimum two Batman in this movie at one they had
Michael Keaton Batman and they also had [__] Ben
Affleck Batman yeah I mean apparently the sequel
has ured challenges outside of the Amber herd SG
and was testing in the 60s before being recut in
the summer of 2022 despite the overhaul the film
continued to test in the 60s prompting another new
cut uh this movie is like the echo of regimes says
one Insider It's the Last Remnant of the snse
and no one really wants to take ownership of it
re-shoot took place right up until this year's wga
stri in May um let's see in fact none of the Stars
caned by Zack Snyder for Batman be Superman da of
Justice and Justice League including Ben Affleck
Henry caval Gadot Ezra Miller and Mamoa will
reprise their roles in the new DC Universe in
character Mamoa May return just not as Aquaman
sources say the actors engage in talks to play
Lobo either in the 2025 reboot Superman Legacy or
in a standalone film that honestly makes absolute
sense to me yeah he looks like Lobo yeah you know
and like if you're gonna get a new Superman you
kind of have to get a new everybody else anyway
like and if you want a clean start if you wanna
the DC Universe begins here all of that makes
sense you know but then again Violet Davis is
going to still be Amanda Waller and uh John Cena
will still be Peacemaker and those things are in
C Josh mundall chat reminded me to promote the
stash reservist list thank you Josh you go to
Jane Silent Bob secret stash friends do you have a
comic book store near you if not man why not order
your comic books like Mark's mace forthcoming
Mace Windu comic book from Jay and Silent Bob
secret stash become a reservist we'll send Comics
anywhere in the continental United States um go
to jany bob.com for more details thank you Josh
mall for that anyway back to what we were talking
about Lobo mimoa is perfect for Lobo yeah um
later on in this variety piece it says at least
two of Amber herd scenes were cut from Aquaman 2
an action sequence had found Meera fighting Black
Manta and a love scene with mimoa according
to individuals familiar with the production
she's probably fighting black man to save her
baby right and so that scene's been cut which
it's like tonally does anybody want in fantasied
in their Aquaman movie not after the first movie
which was just candy colored fish things and
underwater fire I mean could you imagine like
Aquaman one hey here's an octopus playing drums
Aquaman 2 is a dead baby floating at the top of
this T somebody somebody fish that out somebody
get the net and fish it out like I didn't know
this is the movie we were going to get um I'm not
like I'm not saying I'm all for baby killing Bing
stretch to the imagination Mark uh I know that's
a hot take but I'll say it right here that being
said that would not make me leave that movie I
would not be on my feet and like how dare they
I'd be like wow this [__] took a [__] turn
like I gotta see what they do next like of all
the Cinematic bad guys I believe Black Manta now
Takes the Cake I mean at least you know Thanos
was like half of everybody I'll never meet him you
know just [__] what did he say about it he was
like fair or some such [__] balanced balanced
but [__] when you're just like killing babies
[__] man I mean that's that's I could see why
Warner Brothers was like perhaps no although I
will also say and and some of it is always context
right I in Battle Star Galactica the miniseries I
kept watching it because they killed a baby in the
first five minutes of that show when C six when
Trisha helper's walking through that outdoor mall
and she's like oh look at the baby oh they're so
small and fragile and she just sticks her hand in
there and you hear like I'm watching this I gotta
see what they do next if they kill the [__]
baby teaser I forgot about that that was so
[__] Crimson you heard the like little snap and
[__] and at first you were like what the [__]
but then it's like well they're about to drop a
bunch of missiles right it's actually Mercy in
showing a little bit of Merc Mercy but like that
that intrigued me enough to to to keep watching a
4our miniseries but after the again the the weird
like Wonka Vision version of Aquaman you get in in
part one to be like by the way part two killing
babies now not just babies your hero's baby and
like I get it it's in the comics but the Aquaman
Comics were not quite as frothy uh as that movie
was Bobby Hill in chat said hey Kev everyone has
been talking about Obie being he who remains for
weeks Bud yeah I guess but this was exposed
to me here in [__] chat um so strange what
people choose to like like that stuck in his crawl
enough where he was like I gotta write a comment
about this yeah like there's Glenn Alexander in
chat is like Mark have you read Dune the book
Paul's first son gets killed I'm not saying you
can't kill people's Sons yeah like I mean granted
it's awful but I'm not saying you can't do that
in fiction you always always do that in fiction
but it needs to be part of the story that feels
like it's the story you were always telling and
Aquaman does not feel like it's a story that was
going to hold INF fantacide um that's it's a it's
a turn and a pretty harsh turn at that for the
tone that you got in the first one I'm all for
stories that go [__] dark when they when it
feels like a story that's going to go dark but
I don't know it just I could see like because
the first one played like a kids movie and it's
that's a that's a that's a serious left turn for a
kids's franchise yeah again Giant Octopus playing
drums um yeah that movie sounds and how
the the first one made a billion dollars
yeah like an Aquaman movie that made a million
dollars like that's nuts I mean it makes sense
in retrospect but like nobody saw that coming
um and the fact that you do that and then like
you make another one and it has all this trouble
getting to the [__] screen man it's crazy yeah
I don't I don't understand it but very talented
filmmaker too yeah James Juan um but I think you
know some of it is also the watch word that
James gun keeps saying is if script's not
right we're not setting a date for it we're not
starting production all these things tend to go
wrong because they have either no script or a
bad script but they're fenced in by production
commitments I guess they had to make an Aquaman
movie at some point and so they made one and it's
bad um Craven Knight on the in chat said just
watch that Battle Star scene wow yeah it's intense
I remember talking to uh to to Ron Moore because
we had him on the Battlestar galacticast a couple
of times and asked him about that and he
was like yeah sci-fi did not want to let
us do that um and for a very long time that
scene did not have the sound of a baby's
neck snapping it's like I Think We snuck it in
it's like I think we just snuck it in like the
last round of post Andi didn't get a chance to
bounce it um somebody said that uh the crow is
officially been cast and it's the scars guard
kid yeah yeah I think we hit that yeah we hit
that a couple like a month ago or so it's not
it's not new news I that man I think he's a
good cast yeah I mean [__] it I'll go for it
I mean he's no Brandon Lee but sadly nobody is
um as Aquaman has all this [__] trouble
um Barbie became Warner Brothers highest
grossing film ever right yeah yeah higher
than any Batman higher than any uh Harry
Potter and I don't think they had her signed to
a sequel so that's going to cost them if she even
has anything else she wants to say about Barbie
Tully Quinn in chat said Remember When Hawkeye
killed that chicken in the mash finale he didn't
kill the chicken remember I don't so in the mash
finale there's like they're trying to be quiet
and uh there's uh if I remember correctly I know
Hawkeye didn't do it I think he witnessed it and
he talks about it and he breaks down emotionally
um a woman who had like a crying baby and if I
remember correctly they're hiding from aggressors
in the midst of war and uh he tells the story
that she was holding a chicken and the chicken
was clucking and so she killed the chicken to keep
it quiet but then later on spoilers in the episode
they Ral it was not a chicken that she was holding
but a child and you know that was that was in the
mash series finale dude you know what I'm saying
like we're wrapping this show up like [__] a
40-year successful run and let's leave him with
good feelings they like P.S this happened as well
well yeah by the way that's that's a tough one um
TR train said Kevin stop reading chat we're all
insane in here insane over here too kids word them
up infinite mush goes Mash wow yes I know why are
we we're really deep digging far [__] back man
people like Ryder strikes over you guys talking
about [__] the mash series finale watched
programs in TV history indeed uh meanwhile uh
Matthew vaugh uh was at director Matthew Von he
of um the kman series first class KCK ass uh was
at New York ComiCon um just kind of just spinning
wisdom in front of a crowd and talked about his
first experience in the X-Men universe and how
badly it went and he talked about how X-Men the
Last Stand did Hollyberry dirty um he said that
uh he was attached to direct X-Men 3 and he said
I went into one of the executives offices and I
saw an X3 script and immediately knew it was a lot
fatter I was like what the hell is this draft and
the executive went don't worry about it and I'm
like no I'm the director I'm worrying about this
draft the executive wouldn't tell him so V grabbed
it he said and I opened the first page and it said
Africa storm kids dying of no water she creates
a thunderstorm and saves all these children and V
says well I thought it was a pretty cool idea but
once he learned what was going to happen to the
script his relationship to the project sour vgh
said what is this and they said oh it's h Berry
script I went oh okay because she's not signed on
to do the movie yet and the executive goes but
this is what she wants it to be and once she
signs up we'll throw it in the bin the director
said and V's like well you're going to do that
to an Oscar winning actress who plays Storm I'm
out of here so I quit the movie that's [__]
up I mean you know I should really close my mouth
um I'm acting like that Mark that is the single
worst thing I've ever heard but it's pretty
[__] tricky tricky Dicky it's it's a little
skey it's a little like I don't want to play the
race card but it's a little [__] racist like I
know what halberry wants she wants to be in
Africa and save like hungry thirsty kids um
like and also that they we're gonna we're gonna
commission a script that would have no intention
of shooting just to get her to sign on is uh is
some shyy [Music] nonsense good for uh Matthew
vaugh for spilling the tea as the kids used to
say right as the kids used to say granted like
Matthew vau it's good for him for saying you
know what I won't do that to this actress that
seems really [__] up and if you guys are going
to do that I don't want to be a part of it when
he did sign on to X-Men first Class they had
a character named Darwin um played by Ed gei
I think is how you pronounced his last name uh
but his whole power was like I uh I can adapt
to anything and uh and then they kill him like
so the first of these young X-Men you're going
to kill is a black guy who can adapt to anything
really really come on guys they just never learn
you never learn um but anyway um hey while
I'm thinking of it you know I'm sitting uh
this brick wall behind me kids uh I'm at the world
famous improv in the 80s um um you're watching USA
Network and I'm about to do all night I'm about to
do a set yeah it's Friday night at 1 am hb's young
comedy be along very shortly catch a rising
star kids right here catch a rising star in
the8 um I am at SM Castle uh Cinemas here
in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey SM Castle
is right below me and in SM Castle right
below me on November 3rd we got two great
filmmakers coming coming to SM Castle I'm
gonna interview them who are they who are
they why it's the Russo Brothers mark That's
Right Joe and Anthony Russo are coming here
man for a nice chitchat about their their
lives and careers and magical movies that
they've made tickets on sale right now at SM
Castle cinemas.com go scap up your tickets
man it's be a hell of a night chitchatting
with the Russo Brothers man think about it
very nice winter soldier Civil War Infinity
War all the wars no endgame probably secret
War lots to talk about with the really good guys
man the gy man yes yeah as well as all the [__]
they've been doing on you know [__] Netflix
with their extractions app what's their company
called Aba agbo agbo um really nice dudes who I've
spoken to a few times over the years I I [__]
love those two Avengers movies I make no apologies
for that [__] I mean Sito sit not really a hot
take I'm like I like both those [__] Avengers
movies people like everybody likes those [__]
the biggest movies of all time yeah like holy
[__] are you sure you want to say that I'm like
oh yeah I'll say it right here now on Beyonce's
internet you're GNA say that hey B man what's up
if we were in the MCU you know what today is today
is the day that Tony Stark saved half of us so is
that right so all of Avengers endgame took place
in 2023 I guess because of the fiveyear jump yeah
that's what that's what everybody on the internet
was saying October 17 2020 3 is Tony Stark day
this is the day that he [__] pulls all the gems
off of thanos's Fist and [__] dies for all of us
God damn it he took such a [__] punch man like
right before I mean I know it's all fictional and
[__] Thanos isn't even real but uh he [__]
you know when he when he goes for those gems that
like last time before Thanos you when he's like
I am inevitable and he goes to snash watch that
[__] watch how hard Thanos [__] punches that
[__] guy yep again I know we're talking about
like it was a fight a boxing match none of the
shit's real but it's it's [__] nuts man like
two some of my favorite moments in both of those
movies involve people fighting [__] Thanos um
you know naturally of course the [__] you
know Captain America picking up mulling year
is magical and [__] but also [__] Captain
Marvel fighting Thanos where he headbutts her
and she don't even [__] she headbutts right back
yeah oh God so awesome um you took everything from
me I don't even know who you are oh [__] that's
another magical moment you took everything from
me I don't even know who you are you will and
she almost [__] killed him man yeah she's the
one didn't [__] rain fire that was it she was
she [__] took all his clothes off and [__]
she raised him in the air and took his clothes
off she was like look at his little dick she was
going to shame him first everyone looking up in
the air and seeing that purple little set of nuts
hanging out and then she was gonna [__] crush
him and [__] if I was her with all that magic
power if I'm the Scarlet Witch like I'm like a few
minutes away from becoming the Scarlet Witch and
I still have all that power and I hate that [__]
Vision killing piece of [__] I would have [__]
raised him up in the air ripped off his clothes
like she did then ripped off his dick magically
shoved it in his mouth before he had a chance
to rain fire yeah that's what I'm gonna talk to
the Russo Brothers about Mark when they come to
SM Castle November 3D you think that fos knows
what a Colombian necktie is here's where you guys
[__] up okay I've been waiting to say for years
Scarlett wit should have ripped thanos's dick
off shoved it in his mouth first let me tell
you about Columbia Thanos here's what they would
do all the time they're like wasn't it enough
that Thor cut his head off I'm like no no easy he
killed gamor cut his dick off and shove it in his
mouth um all right um moving on yes guo Del
Toro um revealed that he was wanted to make
a Star Wars movie about Jabba the Hut yeah I
read that that would have been fun uh you know
not that long ago in this galaxy guro hoped
to make a Star Wars movie um but he wanted
to tell about the franchise notorious crime
Lord Jaba the Hut um blah blah blah blah blah
yeah apparently you know he wanted to do the
rise and fall of Jabba and his team designed
a great world full of great stuff that dor
was very happy with but it never went into
development ultimately because it's not my
property it's not my money and it's one of
those 30 screenplays that just goes away basically
Lucas film didn't like it enough to put it into
production which you know listen I get
like as much as there's a version of of
you know if you give me an episode of a
TV show that is just the Jaba story sure
to spend a hundred million dollars
on a feature film about Jaba the
Hut not every character needs to be the hero that
we all get to see I'd have been there I'd have
gone for that one but I'm with you I would have
much rather watched the series though Matthew
Herer herard he guardi in chat says technically
they killed the Thanos who hadn't done all the
things they blamed him for yet well technically
they killed both Thanos they killed the Thanos
that [__] snapped everyone out of existence
and then they killed another Thanos who to be
fair was not innocent yeah he did lot of awful
[__] already yeah he just hadn't done the snap
yet but was trying to as we saw the [__] very
end and [__] I get I know this poops back but
God remember how hard he punched Tony [__] Stark
just go back and watch that remember mind watching
[__] you know six kill a baby in Battle Star
Galactica go back and watch Thanos punch [__]
Tony Stark Man how he lives through that hit I'll
never know probably because they're both fictional
but you know the physics of that punch yeah it's
fake physics at best I can't believe we got away
with talking about a gamma the turo [__] jobish
Series without B man jumping in I know seriously
what what do you think bman B the way I would have
done it is like uh four rooms where you're Jaba is
the Anchor Point and you use different aliens
in his court and you tell their stories about
why they're in the court like the old school book
Tales From jabas Palace I think that could be very
compelling that's how I lcas film will never
hire me for anything but that's how I do Sam um
or you get they just did you're doing a comic book
well Marvel hired me lucasfilm just didn't bounce
me um in chat Big T 1377 said Tony Stark built
this in a cave with scraps there's a there's a
great anecdote in the uh in the MCU book about how
dismayed Jeff Bridges was on the set of Iron Man
because like he thought there was a script when
he showed up to go to work he like almost every
day was Ferro and Downey huddled in a trailer for
like five hours inventing that day's work and Jeff
Bridges is just like playing games with the crew
on set and he's like how do you make a movie like
this what is happening it's always been like that
at Marvel from the jump where it's like we like
Downey just wouldn't like what they were shooting
that day so he and favro would just figure it out
as they went and there's a great anecdote where
at one point Ferro was like you know what I think
we're going to kill all this cave stuff at the
beginning of the movie and the production designer
was like John we built the cave we're shooting
the cave it's like oh all right we built the cave
so I guess we'll shoot that stuff and that's the
heart of the movie yeah him and and and yson and
like learning morality and all of that stuff was
gonna go until somebody just literally like we've
already spend millions of dollars building this
cave we're shooting the cave okay did you read
that book I did I uhhuh how fast to read was it um
it was an incredibly fast read because I'm deeply
interested in subject matter and a lot of it was
you know I have been also a careful Observer of
Marvel uh low these past 15 years sometimes as a
journalist sometimes as a watcher and like there
was the stuff that I thought I knew pretty
well the stuff that I kind of like thought
I understood but almost every chapter there's
a thing that I just didn't know that like was
previously hither to withheld from frying eyes
um it's it's an extraordinary piece of work um
so yeah yeah I highly recommend it um I gotta
tell you man it could be what Marvel you know
everyone's like Marvel Marvel's this Marvel's
that could be what Marvel's been missing is
just Robert Downey Jr sounds like he did a lot of
free writing get that guy back in a writer's room
it'll only cost you $50 million more than not how
much did you say one five or 0 0 yeah you're right
about that that's for sure and I'm telling you man
if they want him back it's probably gonna be 100
and they crazy not to pay it at this point I mean
you know there are all the rumors of what secret
Wars is you know either it's some version from the
comic book that we know whatever it is but it's an
opportunity for them to dip back into that [__]
well and just give us the things that they've not
been giving us for the last you know five years or
so and like would they spend $100 million to get
Robert Dy Jr back for one movie for three scenes
in one movie yeah yeah they will will Chris Evans
decide like hey you know what I want to take
one more swing with this Shield like you know
what fine what do you want what do you want you
know and then that also lets them recast things
in continuity that also lets you recast you know
hey we want a different Thor now hey we we want
a different Tony Stark now we still want him to
be in the movies but now as he's being played by
I don't know whomever pick a dude M Molina 2121
in chat says if the MCU doesn't move into X-Men
and fantastic for soon no one will care um he's I
mean I'm not saying he's right 100% but they they
really should [__] start playing their X-Men
cards and their Fantastic Four cards you know
I mean I think Fant all I keep reading about is
like they're gonna reboot at Secret Wars but it's
like yeah well that's [__] that's years from
now I mean you gonna staunch the bleeding before
then I mean our our our friend of the show Matt
shakman is directing Fantastic 4 and according
to him 've already cast it like it's not even
a matter of you know we're not sure it's like
no we know who the cast is they're not announcing
it while the actors are still on strike but they
know who it is oh is that right yeah um as for
X-Men like it's the one thing they actually have
to get perfect um it's the thing that everybody
wants and has always wanted um and so like take
your time absolutely take your time like do not
rush it um which you know if if it was my money
and I know it's not and I know how hard a thing
it is to do but I feel like they should have just
taken a break after endgame like endgame is the
end of that story and the minute we come off of
end game with other movies with other characters
it's like no this is not actually what we want we
actually want it to stop we want it to feel like
an ending because that's the ending um and then
give it a couple of years of not having [__]
superheroes in our faces and then come back strong
whether that strong is Fantastic 4 whether that
strong is X-Men whether that strong is Deadpool
3 which then leads you into the X-Men I don't
know but you know I liked Shang Chu just fine I
didn't really care that much about Doctor Strange
to the internals was whatever um nothing that has
come out since has been like amazing other than
the Sony stuff other than the Spider-Man stuff
and like but hey again we're just we're just
armchair detectiving which is armchair Studio
running it's all dreamy uh what else we got on
the news side uh we got uh a couple stories out
of New York Comic Con um first off Tom Hardy is
getting into comic books with Scott Snider um
the two of them are teaming up for a book called
arcbound with Hardy as the creative collaborator
is the title that he's taking on it uh Scott SN
is writing it along with Frank tier um longtime
Marvel head 12 issue series takes place in a
future where Earth is a Barren Wasteland uh the
formal corporatocracy uh harnesses the unmatched
energy of chronium to assert its Dominion across
the stars and the arcbound series Chronicles the
Journey of Kai a Resolute mediator Captain tasked
with the maintaining of blah blah blah blah blah
um all of that stuff is without context is just
kind of wordy word stuff but I like Scott Snyder
quite a bit I think Tom Hardy is a smart dude um
I'm curious I'm curious um also out of New York
ComicCon um a new comic book production company
called ghost machine was announced ghost machine
comes from Jeff John's um Brad Meltzer um Lamont
McGee uh Gary Frank Brian hitch um Francis
manipol Peter J tamasi like it's something
of an All-Star collaboration between writers and
artists all of which um will Connect into this
vast Universe books are coming out through
image ghost machines and production company
that will already set up these things um in in
in other media I mean Jeff Johns it's hard to
bet against that dude in comics and it's got Brad
Meltzer as well and Brad Meltzer is super smart I
love Brad meltzer's work yeah um Lamont McGee the
secret weapon he was on um Black Lightning for the
entire run he did the Star Wars Jedi Adventures
um super deep nerd I'll see what they're up to
Heavens yes Heavens yes yeah um and then finally
um you know it's been a couple of weeks now but
Keith gfin yes passed away L Keith gfin speaking
of responsible for one of the most fun comic book
runs in uh history they did the Justice League
the fun Justice League Justice League America
Justice League well Justice League it was called
and then they did Justice League Europe Justice
League jli Justice League International um
created the you know uh Blue Beetle the Hae
Rees well no but the blue beo Booster Gold Team
UPS in the old Justice League you know Batman
punching Guy Gardner [__] knocking him out
one punch Jon Jones one punch Oreos later on
becoming choos and stuff um yeah he wrote some
amazing amazing stories how old was he he was 70
years old um did like co-create Rocket Raccoon
yeah created Rocket Raccoon again the H Rees
version of Blue Beetle he created with with John
Rogers and Raphael Albuquerque um and cly Hamner
um yeah his the the announcement of his passing
was as I understand it I've never met ke um but
was perfectly in character where uh on Facebook
Wednesday uh the Wednesday he passed there was a
post pre-written by gfin who knew he was passing
said quote I told them I was sick anything not
to go to New York ComicCon thanks bah oh he
used Baha he did he did that all the time in
the Justice League Comics yeah a stroke is being
attributed as a cause of death what a talented guy
wrote some beautiful stories and and uh wasted my
some of my time in such in the sweetest way thank
you thank you man of words for wasting my time
in the best way possible indeed what a legend
he'll be missed man right much thank but you know
what glad he was here because that incarnation of
the Justice League one of my favorites I loved
reading that those stories issue after issue
um Mark walrus onion in chat says Mark Goddard
who played Major West on Lost in Space he passed
as did Phyllis coats the 1950s Lois the first
liveaction Lois Lane no she also passed s of
[__] as did Piper Lori pass Piper Lori passed
as well I'm going to laugh at you Car's mom also
Twin Peaks also the Hustler what actress she
was uh 91 right yeah yeah yeah man such amazing
life and of course Suzanne Summers passed away
just this weekend sadly um battle with breast
cancer yeah that was the I didn't realize that
was the case CU I was like what she looked so
young even though she was like 77 or 78 she still
looked incredibly young but uh yeah apparently a
b long battle with breast cancer since like the
year 2000 202 23 year battle she married to her
husband for like 55 years man she was as famous
as it got when we were kids yeah man I mean thre's
company it's hard to imagine today how big a show
company was it was like friends bro yeah in terms
of how [__] huge and popular it was they got
a lot of Seasons out of it yeah like it's even
like that that show was huge at a time when every
show was huge you know it's hard to imagine what
those numbers were but there were only three
[__] channels and everybody watching TV was
watching one of three shows at any given time so
even the 20th show in the top 20 was getting 14
15 million people watching it and three company
was a number one show um she was uh George DT
pointed out Suzanne Summers was 76 one day from
being 77 she died day before her birthday Victor
van diagram said did we discuss Arlene sorcin in
another episode um I don't know if we ever did
get to yeah not sure aren sorin passed a couple
months back of course the voice the original
voice of Harley Quinn who I interviewed on Fat
Man on Batman years ago lovely woman and uh you
know is largely responsible for Harley Quinn even
being created in the first place Paul deie will
tell you very true so yes we lost her as well
[Music] um yeah man oh somebody said in chat as
a 90s kid uh F kusma said as a 90s kid she will
always be Carol Foster to me that was from what
step by step yeah I watch that as a George Lucas
kid she'll be the blonde and the white teabird in
American Graffiti that's right before she was on
long before she was on thre's company man she was
the girl in the in the what is it white T Bird
or something um yeah man gosh she worked with
George Lucas all those 70s people knew each other
they were all [__] uh Jim Tomlin pointed out we
missed another one Michael Gambon from Harry
Potter he passed away few a month ago or while
we were off making the movie that's true yeah
man why do all these people have to go don't go
time waits for no person DJ said and the thigh th
Master that's right we didn't [__] that was was
a huge chunk of her [__] career at one point was
thank you Thigh Master red comet said rip to rest
in peace to the best Dumbledore um Michael gamble
um like we talked about that because I remember um
what's his face Shan Harris Richard Harris's son
went on the record saying that like you know my
if anybody could have picked up for my father
like my father always loved Michael gambal's
work um Richard Harris being the the actor who
originated the role on screen of Dumbledore he
was like he always loved his work so we were all
very happy that he was the man chosen to Da the
little silly hat um that all the News That's all
the news my friend there you go kids that's all
that's going on in this business of show um
let's see uh Stanley and chat says any live
shows coming oh hell yeah no idea when and Mark
talking about uh well I mean we'll probably be
doing one at the scum and villain Cantina coming
up in the next month talking about coming out to
to SM Castle in November and doing a thing we're
figuring out dates yeah uh meantime of course uh
as previously mentioned the Russo brothers are
coming to SM Castle November 3rd November 11th
is the Zach and Mary 15th anniversary 15 years
of Zach and muie at smodcastle cinemas.com for
tickets and then December 2nd we have SM aution
which is just a whole auction you know we do
those auctions of props and costumes and and
sign lithographs and [__] like that before
big shows well this is the whole show just in
time for Christmas um I got to go get a charger
because my my laptop is dying so so Vamp will
you come in here and and Vamp Vamp with Mark
and uh let's figure out what our questions
are going to be indeed ask us these questions
three um somebody in chat said American
Graffiti was not filmed in Modesto well
trivia I host trivia on Wednesday nights
I'll be hosting trivia tomorrow night uh
do you know where American Graffiti was
filmed because Modesto was too modern
here's also something crazy American Graffiti
was filmed in like 1973 74 about 1962 if we
made American Graffiti today it would be
about the year 2010 can you imagine how
much of the world changed between 62 to 75 that
you can make a Nostalgia film that was only 10
years old crazy yeah like what's what's
the Nostalgia that anybody has for like
2002 uh I mean I don't I don't think I have
any what do I miss about 2010 uh being in my
20s yeah I have Nostalgia over my knees
yeah remember when my back didn't hurt
just trying to stand up y that was lovely
remember I could eat whatever I wanted to
oh my God that's yeah yeah my metabolism
is what I would make my Nostalgia about I
know I'm powered up kids you fired up
powered up man um all right let's do
this we'll start with this one because we
had two people asked to same question uh
both Robert Mills and Laura D wanted to know uh
what was our favorite trick-or treat costumes
growing up [Music] H well one thing I think
you have to remember about the life that one
LED in the 1970s is that by and large Halloween
costumes were just [__] Hefty trash bags with
appliques of muscles on them um the techn the
costume technology was not advanced in the 70s
um it was it was either paper or plastic um
I almost never got like a customade costume
my mom was not that lady who was sitting down
with [__] sewing machine patterns to figure
out how to make me into Oba Fett or whatever
didn't happen um but I think my favorite was
probably Batman only because I had a cape um
and cap capes with a [__] even though that
Cape was made of plastic um and snagged on
everything um I'm going say Batman what was
the question again Growing Kids go ahead
oh growing up your favorite trick-or treat
costume I mean I remember like a lot of like kids
were bums remember like you'd burn a cork and youd
put like a [__] like five o'clock shadow on
you and you wore ratty clothes and you carried
a bindle stiff um I remember I just remember
that a lot like um my favorite outfit I think
we ever did was me and Bellos Mike bellicose
made Ghostbuster um outfits and our own proton
packs and they the outfits were so [__] good
that Bell CO's brother older brother Timmy and
uh his friend one of his friends borrowed them
for like Henry Hutson senior dress up day [__]
they're pretty good outfits more I think about it
like me and bells did a really nice job um but I
like I like those outfits those was probably the
best Halloween cost I've ever had in my life I was
vman I uh I dressed as Voltron when I was like six
and that was pretty cool you and a couple friends
or just you by yourself I just me by myself it was
me and my brother my brother was a pirate I think
not like just generic pirate and I was Voltron uh
lion Voltron not vehicle Voltron um although well
yeah my favorite Halloween costume of all time
may be uh two years ago we dressed my daughter
up as the staypuff marshmallow man when she was
like 11 months old and I went as a Ghostbuster
and that was pretty cool that's dope but I had
like money so I bought the big Proto I I went
full out for it you know you didn't make yours out
of cardboard box no I was 40 years old when I went
so I I hit shouldn't it technically have gone the
other way shouldn't she have been a Ghostbuster
and you were the state Puff Marshmallow
Man yes although she has like the chubbi
that would have made a lot of sense but chubby
Baby Wise I could see yeah he Michelin man that
kid let's see uh keeping with the Halloween
theme uh what's the movie that scared you the
most as a kid and what's the movie that scared
you the most as an adult that's from Shelby
Fielding say again scariest uh movie you saw when
you were a kid scariest movie you saw as an adult
scariest movie I saw when I was a kid um when I
was a little kid it was [Music] um was it don't
be afraid of the dark with little creatures that
lived in the baseboard were like always Whispering
they would whisper and like they [__] the lady
shrinks down and is captive with them for all
eternity at the end of the FL it was a TV movie
oh damn terrifying um but uh The Shining erased
that for me uh as a kid the two twin girls in The
Shining still unnerve me to this day um and as an
adult I mean nothing that scares me but one of
the most unnerving scenes I remember from like
a quasi horror movie um there's a movie with Jeff
Goldblum called Mr Frost where he plays the devil
essentially he's a guy in an insane asylum with
Kathy Baker I think her name is and uh he is uh
like he maintains he's the devil and she's like
yeah right and then over the course of the movie
he kind of proves that he is uh but there's a at
one point she's watching a video um of I guess
either child abuse or a child killing and God this
is horrible this is the second time this come up
in the [__] show today uh but uh it's her face
Kathy Baker's face while she's watching this thing
you don't see the thing you just see her turn a TV
on that goes from static to this image then cuts
to her face and she's watching and you just hear
this kid very like lightly crying and instantly
she [__] like like she she plays it I'm I'm
doing it I'm not doing it justice the horror in
her face like told the story way better than any
Grizzly image would have and she shuddered and
started crying and stuff that always stays with
me because it's like you never saw what they saw
you know when we were kids we had Faces of Death
and [__] like that and the older got the more
you realize oh they made up a lot of that [__]
it wasn't and this was made up too but my God it
just [__] it chills me the [__] out there um
The Exorcist was the scariest movie that I saw as
a kid um I remember seeing it I must have been
like 12 or 13 and held such disain for it I was
like it's [__] this movie was made the same
year I was born how scary could it be and then
I watched it and you know it's it's the kind of
horror that that I remembered I Remember Loving
in the way that one loves horor in that it was
almost entirely cerebral it was never the the gore
that got me was never the the the viscera that got
me was always the the intellectual of it the like
just thinking about the the what possession
is what possession means and that idea of of
you were not in control of your own body you're
not even a passenger anymore um I just remember
it frightening the [__] out of me um like I was
hiding behind a couch building like a pillow fort
to keep the movie further away from me um because
I was an adorable kid 1983 um today you know like
I I am not a horror movie person I've I've I've
exclaimed that to the to the to the highest that
I just I don't I do not enjoy um jump scares I
do not enjoy the that that feeling um so like The
Money Pit is a movie that scares me today the idea
is like oh [__] real estate horror like I bought
a house that I thought was going to be great and
I end up sinking a fortune and Sanity into it yeah
that's scary to me you know like you know Falling
Down is a movie that's scary to me there there
are documentaries that are scary of like oh yeah
no this is the world you guys by the way we are
barely hanging on um but but yeah because I'm not
a hard person it's not it that that is not a that
is not an itch that I try to scratch um the world
can be scary enough yeah Victor van diagram said
Wall Street where the bad guy becomes the hero
to an entire generation of people yeah like fight
Club is scared you know like I remember seeing
that movie like three years ago um for the first
time since it was in theaters like oh [__] no
this is just how terrorists get made oh this is
just this is just like unchecked you know aimless
rage oh okay I get it yeah this is awful The Joker
The Joker for me I watched that like during the
pandemic and I was like oh my gosh this just feels
irresponsible film ramblings with hero 004
said Kevin Tony had made contact with the
gauntlet and taken the Stones by the time
Thanos punched him he was using the power
of one of the stones to take the power of
the punch you buy that uh I don't buy Tony
Stark knowing how to modulate and employ the
use of individual Stones the minute he gets
it granted he's a very smart guy but I
don't I don't I don't quite buy that I
think he just took a [__] shot to the chops
um and the suit has some impact resistance and
shock absorbing natures and all that [__]
it is a suit of armor after all but still
still um you know what's [__] scary funny
games did you ever see that movie oh [__]
you're absolutely right it is that is a terrifying
and unnerving movie both versions both Michel and
the Remake are [__] terrifying um how those kids
like address the camera how they are just with the
family but then when they address the camera
gets even more good good call that is a [__]
unnerving movie you know because it is just like
we're going to do violence because we want to do
violence and nobody asked for it nobody [__]
walked into it like nobody did anything wrong
it is just chaos arriving in your house and
you can't do anything about it that [__] is
frighten I uh I was terrified as a kid nightmares
terrified of Labyrinth I think I watched it too
young and just Goblin puppets just absolutely
scared me and it was like I I probably saw it
when it came out on video so 86 or 87 so maybe
I was five or six years old and it was like real
like the goblin could come and actually take you
um and I had a baby sister it was yeah Labyrinth
and then uh I went I made the mistake of going to
the movie theater to see Event Horizon when that
came out oh [__] that [__] scene of Madness
that's oh wow that was a mistake uh because I
thought it was a sci-fi movie I do not like horror
movies at all um like Mark they gotcha and uh yeah
I was like wait yeah at about 45 minutes into that
movie I was like oh this is a bad idea yeah yeah
and again there are movies that I you know I've
never seen it follows um but I like the idea is
frightening like you know what good enough I get
it fine uh I will grant you that that's probably
scary um else you know who I saw in the picket
line who leslieanne Warren from clue clue Miss
scarlet and I was like I loved you in clue and
she was walking and you know she's she's a woman
of a certain age but uh I was like I was at my
friends movie theater and we programmed it and
an audience of like 200 people laughed their
asses off she was like a your heart thank you
rock um all right last question we go kids last
question of the evening man this is from uh ear
Mixon wants to know on jml midnight in chat no
jml in chat says midnight showing of The Blair
Witch the week could open remember remember that
[__] end of the movie where Mike is facing the
wall and she's just Heather is just screaming and
[__] oh my God I was in Sun I started Sundance
you were there I was there for that for that
year and like the mixture of no idea what it
was plus like thin atmosphere and exhaustion like
[__] I have told this story many times but uh
John Pearson who repped uh was the producers
rep on clerks one of my dear friends uh he was
involved with the Blair Witch kids that started
kind of as a short on his show uh split screen
they kind of showcased the legend of the Blair
Witch there before they finished the movie for
uh you know um who put that out wasn't Lion's gate
um um they don't mirax right was it mirax or New
Summit I forget it's company I don't think was it
Li's k no what was the name of that Artis and AR
in the US they don't exist anymore they were like
they were kind of a quasi mirax uh almost a 24ish
of their time Artisan made like kind of classy
movies any event that yeah that was [__] that
[__] was the story I've told before Pearson
repped that movie so he had given me a copy on
VHS and I hadn't watched it and so they went
to Sundance and the buzz out of Sundance was
huge and um Jennifer schwabach who I was like in
a brand new relationship with at that point she
was like you know I I've I told her I was like
hey man there's all this Buzz about this movie
called The Blair Witch Project we have it on VHS
do you want to watch it tonight and she was like
yeah okay and so we started watching it and I fell
asleep I was just not because of the movie I was
just tired and [__] um although the movie is not
like you know [__] keep you awake it you know
PLS along in the beginning and stuff so I fell
asleep watching it and I get woke woken up by the
end of the movie by a hysterical Jennifer Schwab
he's like oh my god get up get up and I was like
what what what F what's happened what happened
and she was like these kids what's going on like
why won't anybody help them and I was like what
what do you mean and she's like why won't anybody
help them like they were how could this [__]
happen why won't anyone help these kids and I'm
like this this movie's not real and she's like
what and I was like this isn't [__] real it's
just make pretend this it just looks real because
this is one of the first found footage movies
right so she's like I believe you I was like I
can call John Pearson man he'll [__] tell you
the same thing I was like [__] [__] you ask
Stan grman he'll tell you the same [__] Fargo
[__] and so she was like [__] and I was like
I called up John Pearson who was at Sunday and I
was like John like [__] Jennifer is freaking
the [__] out she just woke me up because she
thinks Blair Witch Project is real I was like
can you talk to her and he said yeah I'll talk
to her and I handed her the phone I couldn't hear
their conversation but all I heard was her going
John why won't anyone help and and then there's
silence and he goes she goes are you sure she
goes I don't believe you and and silence and then
she's like oh she's like and the other she go I
get it was it was [__] over 20 years ago
this happened I hear you but I'll never
[__] forget her being like why wouldn't
even help them that's how [__] that's how
realistic that Blair Witch Project movie
was she [__] [__] out of it man even
help them like it broke her brain like we're
watching a movie where these [__] kids are
being imperiled but nobody will help them and
I'm like yes like didn't you piece all this
together um all right what's our last
one last one uh you told me that it
was real I did in the beginning I was
like this you're I was like this is a
real documentary let's watch it good
night and I fell asleep watching help
them
John um okay what is it uh shifting gears
completely ear Mixon uh if you could make any
character from Comics Speaker of the House who
do you pick I mean Captain America or Superman
are my top two choices um because you know
what they keep telling us in the news this
job is makes you [__] second in line to the
presidency or third in line to the presidency
so I would want somebody third in line to the
presidency that you know historically we could
trust aair scrupulous moral character so
you got uh one of those cats although I'm
tempted to make Batman the house Speaker
you'll never see him no where is he come
out of nowhere and [__] it would hit hard
yes the congressman from Gotham uh does he
gonna say not today um hands down I I I I say
Superman although Superman used to be about
truth justice the America way and now he's
like truth justice and get out of my way no
they Chang what is what it's not the American
way now it's just truth justice and the and
uh and let's say justice again and even more
Justice my left hand is truth my right hand is
Justice um what about you um you know like
there's there's the ideological way to go
which I feel like the the Steve Rogers version is
pretty strong um but I I I'm feeling either like
RoboCop or or Dr Manhattan you are in
violation of vote now where there will
be trouble Dr Manhattan oh that'd
be badass you know like some I said
leave me home they all go away teleports
[__] both houses some place where is he
now he's on Mars but he's also here and
he's also voting but he's also redefined
democracy uh Hey man we can't uh Finance
the government if the [__] government's
not here where did he send him like he
sent him to Mars to a Crystal Palace
so they can sort out this [__]
he hit him with the [__] real
gavl I like robocup I think Alex Alex Murphy um
he's seen some [__] about some [__] um knows
him know knows what to buy for a dollar and what
not to buy for a dollar um you know understands
the way the legal system works because it's
been written into his programming um as long
as he's not a pawn of of ocp of omni consumer
products I feel like he's a he's an upstanding
American and he'll get it done from [__] artha
Franklin from The Blues Brothers you better think
about what you're trying to do to me you better
think like it also all those proceedings musical
I mean I mean they could always break out in a
song it'll be like c rock but for the House of
Representatives so weird you say that because
that's the first thing that went through my
head too I try I was building a coop Rock joke and
then I was abandoning it because I was just like
you know [__] that would be dope man if [__]
like C-SPAN would be would become like MTV time
hearing she burst out in the song and [__] house
music all day long House of Representative music
it was always you better think yes like all right
what are we trying to do to you you try to pass
this law that nobody wants pass trying to put
this motion into motion too much motion don't
use to me what about you B man uh everything
that's happening in Congress reminds me of kind
of like a sarcastic reality show I think Deadpool
would be a great ring leader for a bunch of
clowns I mean it'd be musty
TV whichever site you're
on Scott Levy said The
Punisher that is definitely a choice
hay wave said don't you blaspheme in
here two whole Fried Chickens he wants four
Fried Chickens and a coke the one dry white
toast and the other wants four Fried
Chickens and a coke Jake [__] that's
the Blues Brothers Matt Guitar Murphy
yeah coming here like a couple htic
Diamond meres murf and the magic [Laughter]
tones disain in his voice murf uh what about
you B man who' you pick dead Pi Deadpool
Deadpool oh Deadpool that's right we did
them all s bper speaker Evan Fowler
said in chat bring me my cheese whiz
boy that was somebody who worked on the show
like casting director or costumes or something
like that that the guy who says that in the
Blues Brothers of crew um the show band danced
danced J2 K2 said jolia Jake and lwood blues
won't you welcome from citt City Illinois the
show band of Juliet Jake and lwood blues the
blues brothers [__] they put cab Callaway
in a movie yeah c not only they put him in the
movie they gave him a full ass [__] song yes
and he had and a huge part a meaningful [__]
part and this is a guy who like was the King
of The Cotton Club at one point so much so that
yeah like when they jump into that [__] dance
you know mini the MRA number that's that's what
his life looked like when he was younger at the
Cotton Club yeah the band stand and the [__]
three-piece tuck and the top hat and all of the
[__] bandas and tuxes and everything could
you imagine like your cab Callaway and you're
like well you know I had my moment and [__]
you know cotton club's gone and everything's
different now and you're in the 80s and [__]
and [__] like two of the hottest comedians
on the planet come to you and they're like we
want you to do that thing that you used to do
we want you to do mini the mucher like in this
[__] giant [__] off movie and we're going
to make it look like it did back when you were
at the Cotton Club like are you updating it at
all no we want you to do mini the mucher the same
way you would have done it in 1938 okay kind of
beautiful like when you think about you know they
fought them really hard they uh Dan award and and
John Landis and of course John Belushi wanted
to bring in all these soul and blues Legends
and whatnot and um music legends and uh the studio
of course was like like they wanted them to bring
in the band that did Car Wash which in arguably
is a great [__] slaming get me wrong car wash
but they had their own whole ass movie and
whatnot but uh you know these cats Belushi
and and particularly Dan Aid and and I guess
to a lesser degree John Landis they wanted like
classic Legends they fought for him and they got
him and like you know because the studio is like
come on man artha Franklin Ray Charles [__]
cab Callaway these people haven't had [__] you
know hits and whenever and then artha Franklin
went on to like hit the charts again remember
oh yeah who zooming who and [__] like that
I mean and I'm sure it helped that that was a
relatively cheap movie despite destroying
every car that existed in Detroit at the
time um you and they actually dropped a car
not in Detroit but in well I mean they were
in Chicago they went to nearby [__] where
did they drop that car I want to say it was
in Chicago um I read about it online but they
dropped a car like in dropped it for the Nazi
car that takes uh Michelle D in chat says cab
Callaway actually didn't want to do Minnie the
Moocher because he was pushing a disco version of
the song at the same time so here we were going
like oh c Callaway must have been so excited
he was like you are [__] my disco [__]
up I got these platform shoes I got the [__]
disco ball Rose Royce that's who sing Car Wash
um John Lee Hooker is just out on the street
does doesn't even talk just little boom boom
yeah hey hey Carwash equals Rose Royce the entire
soundtrack the first of the soundtrack album oh
how how how rest in peace Jordan Peters says rest
in peace to our princess Carrie fiser that's right
she was in there as well Frank Oz as well Stephen
Spielberg Stephen Spielberg yeah Frank O T T Train
said Frank O is the Govern guy out to lunch no
Frank Oz was the guy you know who's like one one
prophylactic you when he's checking out Jake in
the he's the evidence guy mustering them out of
prison and Spielberg is the guy who's out to lunch
that they gotta pay Cook County assessor's office
[Music] right come on
[Music] hey Stanley said did Kevin get an award in
Jersey I did I got from the mommoth Arts folks I
got uh momth Arts after dark folks I got is it
a sexy award yeah I did it's where is it it's
over there but it's really nice piece of glass
um after dark and I'm getting another award on
Thursday from the good folks the friends
of firefighters which is an event the gala
event fundraiser event I'll be hosting on the
Thursday hey B man put it up it's right there
help out who don't [__] love firemen uh you
want to help out some fireman kids go bid you
you bid on uh win uh a birth if you will on
The Good Ship Jay and Silent Bob when we go
Cru es skew in February me and Mark will be on it
doing Beyond that's like four months from now yeah
it's coming close man it's coming like Christmas
and [__] well after Christmas um that's right
kids four months from now you can spend three
days on a boat with me and Mark and Jason Muse
Brian o holler Jeff Anderson Jason Lee Ethan
S Jennifer schwabach Ralph Garmin Andy melish
the list goes on and on Cru J and Sal Bob's
cruises Q jbob crues qq.com for more details
see me and Mark do fat man at se in international
waters love fat man we're gonna get out there and
we're gonna have knife fights and [__] oh F man
now look at that look at those cats who are those
clowns I don't know what's going on there J put an
ad up that's what it looks like look at that look
at look at all the fun activities we got going
on join us on the high se's Kev kids Kev yeah I
was reading James B Smith said Kev has owning
a movie theater given you a wider perspective
on film and storytelling n not so much on film
and storytelling because I spent a good portion
of my life inside movie theaters long before I
bought one it does as an exhibitor make me very
conscious of the running time of movies I used
to never care I used as a filmmaker I'm like hey
man make a movie as long as you want [__] or as
short as you want but you know it's usually long
movies that people complain about um so I was
never one of those cats I'm like hey man it's
your testimony do whatever you want but now as
a guy who uh as a film exhibitor somebody who's
like making money off of movies that play in his
theater or not really the theater the movies draw
people in then selling popcorn to those to those
folks that's where the real money is instead now
I now I'm like hyper sensitive to running times
of movies because if you give me a three-hour
movie [__] man that's one less Showtime we
got to earn back that money and stuff um keep
them short that's what I say welcome to killers
of the flower Moon how long is that movie 32
something
really all right all right all right I can't
argue with him man like scorsi uh this kid
he I think he's got a future in film he seems
to know what to do with a camera I think he's
gonna be around for a long time so I'll give it
a shot almost four hours wow Jose monster asked
what movies did I buy from Criterion well I'll
tell you but J I got the OG out of the Living
Dead I got Wall-E uh Malcolm X The Princess
Bride Devil in a Blue Dress police Story one
police story two box set Silence of the Lambs and
Godzilla 1954 that's what you bought yeah I went
for it um stoic Nick said it's called Cinema
LOL what just because it's long cinema cinema
Cinema's long 24912 said wasn't Taylor's movie
almost three hours was that concert movie very
long I don't know I don't know the running
time of it I mean the thing of it is if an
audience likes it it almost doesn't matter
how long it is and clearly hundred million
dollar any a weekend it didn't hurt nobody
wild Samurai put in chat killers of the tiny
bladder it's good joke Wally unrated yeah
yeah jig me all that people talking about
the liveaction Gargoyles that apparently there's
somebody online let slip yeah now Disney plus is
making a liveaction gargoyles TV show which glad
for them I uh I don't have any GS love or hate it
was just not my jam yeah it was kind of after us
a little bit after Batman the Animated Series if
I remember correctly mhm super Sean 064 in
chat said the Marvel's only an hour and 45
minutes seen a lot of stories I mean
for whatever this is worth take it
with a grain of salt that uh says that uh
their box office ain't going to be it's
not tracking huge uh the Taylor movie is
two hours and 48 minutes according to Mike
W it's a concert yeah if you're a [__]
fan that's that's a lot of entertainment
um well so we got anything else I'm uh the
the tank is empty the cupboard is bare now
people are just repeating stories
that we've already done like Best
Buy is gonna stop carrying DVDs like
we know gargoyles with Keith David yes
um I'm trying to think see if there's anything
else no no yeah why it buts said killers of
the flower Moon made in Oklahoma they have
great film tax rebates Rich good to know man
guys did you watch the boys gen V yet I have
not is that cartoon live action it's the
it's the college set I gotta try that out
um the uh let's
see Napoleon Movie says Virginia native yes
they've made one really Scott quack Phoenix
not even trying to do a French accent Rob yeah
he's taking the [__] Kevin cner and Robin Hood
approach hey yep it's like you know what I
can't do it it's going to sound weird if I
try it's the it's the the Clooney Clo's Boston
in a perfect storm is non-existent Right Robert
Mills said Keith David is horak you're absolutely
right man you're absolutely right Masters of the
Universe Revolution coming at the top of 20124 I
think there's a trailer coming in November geek
we that's right um ear Mixon said when is your
movie coming out my movie I we just finished it
just finished shooting find out soon as I know
I'll tell you believe me I'll be all over that
uh well there it is kids we did a lot of lot of
chitchatting Virginia native said Invincible new
trailer also oh for season two loved Invincible
I look forward to watching season two are they
dropping all the episodes at once I don't know
nothing about toxy um have they apparently it's
screamed at Fantastic Fest to rapturous reviews
response people liked it they seem to have yeah
um that's uh um Peter Dinklage right uh Seattle
K says The Rocketeer is also coming to Disney
plus what um it's it's a thing that's been in
the works for a while um Yello um rock uh yeah
where he plays like she finds the rocket pack
yeah I think he plays like a former Tuskegee
Airman and she finds the rocket pack and they
hard a new writer for it but yeah it's it's
not a new thing there was just a a little bit of
momentum shift on it but I'm here for it I love
The Rocketeer um Scott Pilgrim TV series cartoon
looks great trailer looks amazing trailer looks
good yeah and they got the whole cast back all
the voices right it's like all the voices yeah
you know and I think they I remember listening
to a quote from uh from like Edgar R and and
and uh Brian leoi and and Ben David kinsky
who's they're all producing it together so
that one member of that cast said no it would
have kind of scuttled it because we just didn't
want to recast anybody but everybody was down and
came in and get to play in chat Evan Fowler says
no two halves for invincible season 2 one
next month one next year four UPS each all
right uh Charles Palama asks what's
your favorite film you've screened at
SM Castle a great question you
mean like one of mine or just
anything
you know maybe the Jersey Girl the uncut Jersey
girl yeah I hadn't seen that in [__] ages and
stuff Raquel came out for it that was a good
time um all right kids we've got uh all I hear
Laura D says all I hear about my house to my
teenager is Five Nights at Freddy's going to
the Almo Draft House for the first time
to see it that's a video game right and
they turned into a movie um yeah I think
I think I don't I don't I don't know the
I just remember that my my son was all about
five minutes at Freddy's and I'm not sure if
you encountered it as a game or as like
a short or as some kind of viral online
thing um YouTube whatever um I don't really
know it skipped me it went all the way past
[Music] me
um James B Smith says as a big fan of Chasing
Amy will the documentary be a good affirming
watch yeah chasing Chasing Amy which opened the
mod Castle second annual SM Castle Film Festival
um was uh really really great Sav did a job with
that document um get schwifty said your favorite
Kevin is the moot one that makes the theater
money yeah I love any movie that [__] sells
out and stuff like that um speaking of which Zach
and Mary Mega porno 15th anniversary screening
coming up but before that me and the Russo
Brothers November 3 get your tickets now kids
go to smodcastle cinemas.com it's only about three
more events for smodcastle for the end of the year
there's the Russo Brothers there's Zach Mary mea
porno there's Smokin Josh mundal just pointed out
that Moonlighting is on Hulu now you were talking
about before we went right I was yeah I watched
the pilot and I was and I haven't seen it in 30
some odd years because I watched it first run um
maybe I saw reruns of the season the summer that
it had aired but like it had never really I think
it gotten a home video released that I didn't
bic is whatever and I was astonished to discover
that I remembered every scene in that pilot and
that's a long than 90-minute pilot and I'm like
I remember this bit I remember this bit oh he's
gonna say this now I remember like it this weird
sense memory of Moonlighting it's like oh yeah
know this is the finale when they have to climb
the ladder to get up to the to the clock face
at the the Eastern Standard Building and she's
going to hang on and then he puts a lad but the
ladder tips and like all of it just kind of came
flooding back scene by scene by scene um it's a
it's a well- constructed pilot um David is and
the pilot like that character is not very well
modulated so he's aot yeah he's he's not quite
the David Addison we come to know and love Yeah
like he's he's kind of an [__] and kind of a
little toxic um too much it feels like and even
and syil Shepard is not also understanding the
sort of comedy of it and so like it's it's a weird
it's Proto Moonlighting it's not Moonlighting yet
but like you see why they green L it to a series
you see you see the bones of what it was going
to be but it uh it would take a little bit to
get there it's a fascinating watch Moonlighting
kids now available on Hulu took a while to get
there they had to change some of the songs if I
remember correctly yeah music rights I think was a
big deal um which is a lot of the reasons why some
of your favorite shows aren't on the air because
the music the music Deals they could cut um in
the 80s and 90s are far different from the music
deals that you have to clear today and so um it
took a while and yet to your point I think they
did have to swap out a couple songs to to get it
through hey kids here's something I never [__]
say don't you go ahead and smash that like button
o smash it why don't you go smash that subscribe
button kids smash the like smash the Subscribe
do what whatever I think we're GNA smash tonight
yeah man smash right now it's at 293 I like this
come on smash that like button kids Smash It smash
It smash it you're doing it we're doing it we're
smashing T right but I don't know what that gets
us if anything um there it is kids do you have a
good time did you learn a thing or two well well
that's because why is Kev doing a bedtime voice
lol am I what's my bedtime did you get all sexy
hey jul AB Julian Abby says I've been subscribed
for 10 damn years that's right Julianne you and
me get Smash Bros yeah Smash Bros um there it
is kids do you have a good time well if you liked
this and there'll be more of this where this came
from uh Virginia native says freaking 2 am I'm
bed I'm bedtime typing yeah it's 1:30 here in
in the east coast you're a soldier nin schwat
says Uh Kevin Smith After Dark that's right
Mike Ono said how is Kevin liking living in the
valley nice I like that I've always been a big
Valley kid I love the valley man ever since I
saw Bad News Bears I was like I want to be in
this Valley you will you will have been glad
to miss this week because it's like 95 degrees
this week for reasons that you know it's the
end of the world so sure why not October um
it is uh yeah it's been it was a beautiful like
630 uh 65 to 70 degrees here for the last few
days real nice nice now we're just talking
weather time to get the [__] out of here
man yep how's the weather by you at morning
couple old men discussing the weather kid
you had a good time if you did because B man
brought us right into your [__] homes give
it up for B man there he is waving at you and
[__] don't forget uh this week uh I'm going
to be in Brooklyn the friends of firefighter
event a Gala uh at uh on Thursday um and then
uh I'll be back out here on the East Coast for the
Russo Brothers on the 3 and Zach and Muay on the
11th said hi December 2nd me and Mark are gonna
figure out when we're coming back bringing it
back bringing it back maybe we'll bring a movie
back too yeah let's do that I know when you when
you when can you start like just selling tickets
for Splinter and [__] can you do that are you
allowed to do that or no I can you know I think
we're probably uh at the end of the festival run
um so I mean [__] like distribution for shorts
is a weird thing because hardly anybody does it
because there's very little money in it but I
know a guy with the movie theater you know a
do with the movie theater $400 a ticket let's
make some money yeah it's a dollar a minute um
$15 admissions dollar a minute everybody wins
um yeah man we'll figure it out we'll figure
it out definitely want to come back East there's
a Broadway show I have to go see I gotta hit the
great white way Gutenberg the musical oh yeah
friend of mine was asking me if I wanted to
invest in it but he hit me at a time where I
was financially strapped um but they've also
asked me to come play for a day on that show
oh you should go the date that I'm going I'll
find out I'll find out when it is yeah because
uh one of my very best friends wrote that play
you should Brown yeah really Scott Brown
was my assistant at Entertainment Weekly
um uh he was an awful assistant but a very good
writer um then went on to be the theater critic
for the for vulture I think for the for New York
Magazine then worked on a show called Manhattan
then worked on a show called Castle Rock he's
the guy who led me to join the staff at Castle
Rock he made the introduction for me he wrote
the book for Beetlejuice bless you thank you
did he really he did and Gutenberg is a show that
he wrote when he was working for me at at ew like
it's been 15 years like I saw it off off off off
Broadway with him uh and his buddy Anthony King
in the starring rols and they resurrected it 20
years later with Josh Gad and Andrew Reynolds
and so I kind of I I I feel a moral and comedic
obligation to go see this play nice and so uh it's
GNA definitely be that week that I'm back uh to
do fat man so [__] yeah um that's pretty dope
right there man um hey kids uh if you're if you
like the intelligent part of the show uh that's
because Mr intelligence himself over there he
keeps it smart I keep it nice and [__] dumb
he keeps it dirty um give it up for the great
Mark Bernard thank you doubt beisha in chat
says any interest in Back to the Future of the
musical and then right above him Cur cat film
says did Kev see the Jaws Broadway play the shark
is broken so two plays on Broadway right now based
on Steph Spielberg movies Stephen Spielberg
is the king of the great white way very much
getting paid House of Rio said thank you again
for making my patrol a lot easier tonight well
thank you for hanging out with us there House
of Ria indeed keep an eye on CME thanks to all
of you folks for hanging out with us as we pop
the culture right in the [__] mouth um there
it is kids somebody said am me go away says why
no sponsors nobody likes us yeah get cius yeah
you know the sponsor is tonight SM Castle Cinemas
yep SP Joy right below me man I may be upstairs
at the 80s improv in front of this brick wall
but right below me is mod Castle Cinemas kids
come see the Taylor Swift movie come see dumb
money come see we're playing Beetlejuice this
week um come on down come to SM cast of Cinemas
kids sponsor of this year episode of whatever
we call this [__] almost two o'clock in the
morning like what's going on this A Late Late
Late Late Late Show are we still talking
go home uh there it is kids we'll be back
again before uh the end of the month that's
for damn sure because we do have an ad and
maybe we'll do it live yeah we'll probably
do it maybe we'll do it in scum and villainy
cantina so you can sit there stand there and
look at us or sit there and look at us throw
tissue at us hit us real hard that's how
drink your drink your blue drink just have
a good Fu that blue milk tie one on with
blue milk start being honest and [__] uh
there it is my friends there it is what else
what else can I tell you I could show you
this it's [__] gorgeous book yeah heavy yeah
it's bigger than my head they put uh Guardian
devil into this oversized book that gorgeous
cassada and Patti artwork in oversized pages
that's available right get signed to Jane
Silent Bob secret stash become a reservist
at Jane Silent Bob secret stash go to job.com
for more information kids we're gonna get the
[__] out of here it's 1:30 in the morning on
the East Coast indeed gotta move my car before
I get a ticket can't park on First Avenue past 2
am yeah um there it is my friends go be kind to
other people in this world go say something
nice to somebody close your laptop go say
something nice to somebody who deserves it maybe
say something nice to somebody who don't deserve
it maybe that'll flip him around you know when
I go out to eat I used to work in restaurants
when I was a kid and so I always like to tip
well because as a bus boy I earned 15% of the
waiter or waitress's tips and [__] like that so
I've always been like a pretty good Tipper um my
brother who's been in restaurants his whole
life um gets irritated when ever I tip poor
servers like he's like I'm a [__] waiter
for a living and I can't stand F like I why
would you tip because I I tip 50% he's like why
would you [__] tip 50% like that service suck
I was like because when I leave and that person
like sees that tip you know maybe maybe they'll
change their [__] ways or something like that
I don't know so you never know man just go say
something nice to somebody watch the trickle
down you know some people some people need to
hear something nice maybe you're one them maybe
maybe you need to hear something nice here I'll
tell you something [__] nice kids you are smart
and good very clever go give somebody head yeah
wait what did she say go get somebody head I don't
think that's what I was getting at Mark but yes in
short um all right there it is my friends
uh for fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm
Mark Bernard tune in next time same fat Time
same fat Channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss everybody live long and
prosper this is the m greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask keev anything every
Saga has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and S Bob get old up Kevin Smith J